in this article by Michael Levin and
Wendy Bean the importance of tissue
Remodeling and maintenance of proportion
during organism-wide tissue scaling for
regenerative medicine is discussed while
it was known that making new cells alone
was not enough for tissue regeneration
it wasn't clear whether new cell
production and remodeling were a
separate or integrated process this
study on planaria invited a specific ion
transporter h plus K plus atpase that
regulates tissue remodeling via
apoptosis during regeneration the role
of membrane depolarization calcium entry
and apoptosis in shaping the tissues was
also explored the study provides new
genetic entry points into how remodeling
events are coordinated with
predetermined templates for shape
determination the research shows that
these ions play a key role in
determining anatomical polarity and
regulating shape determination and
allometric scaling during regeneration
the concept of morphallaxis was also
discussed with the focus on the signals
directing the scale and geometry of the
processes during regeneration this can
be summed up as the change in membrane
voltage is critical for morphogenesis